el IVA no lleva sin presidente desde el
pasado mes de octubre desde que terminó
el mandato de seis años de Michelle aún
Y todavía su señorías no se han puesto
de acuerdo en elegir a un nuevo jefe de
estado Este ha sido la décimo segunda
vez que han fracasado en el parlamento
en la lección hartos de la inestabilidad
política de la crisis económica que
mantiene paralizado el país algunos
libaneses decenas de ellos han salido a
protestar como ahora mismo vamos a
conocer la opinión de Linda porque han
querido pedir que por fin haya un
presidente y apoyar a los parlamentarios
que han dicho basta
Hoy estamos aquí frente al parlamento
libanés para exigir un presidente
nacional no sectario y sin influencias
de afuera que ayude a limpiar toda la
suciedad y corrupción un presidente
nacional que acabe con la crisis del
dólar y que esté al lado de todos los
libaneses
el parlamento fue fundado por el pueblo
y por lo tanto trabaja para el pueblo
hoy es un deber y una ley la número 74 y
75 que hayan elecciones presidenciales
consecutivas hasta que alguien resulte
electo debe mantenerse alejado de los
partidos y personas que arruinaron el
país y causaron la peor crisis económica
en los últimos 40 años
el país del Cedro navega la deriva sin
presidente ni gobierno y con la moneda
local en caída libre cuando hoy ha
alcanzado un mínimo histórico de un
cambio de 50.000 libras libanesas por un
dólar cuando en 2019 eran 32 dólares
esto significa que hoy el sueldo medio
de un libanés no es más de 75 Dólares